you
yeah I mean I wrote a whole book on
checklist he'd be you know why in the
world would anybody write a whole book
on checklist and it was the last thing I
thought I would be writing about but
I've been fascinated by how we grapple
with risk and complexity in medicine and
i got assigned a project to try to find
a way to reduce deaths and surgery we
have been struggling with our
performance and so I started looking at
how people in other fields grapple with
the enormously increasing complexity
that people in professional worlds are
dealing with and what I found was in the
aviation and skyscraper building and
other lines of work that there was
something really fundamental going on we
had transformed from a world where
ignorance was our biggest struggle as
human beings this is the way it was for
millennia we didn't understand why the
human body failed how to how to build
things really well how to how to do many
many kinds of tasks in the right way
that knowledge was missing today however
our biggest struggle is with what people
call ineptitude meaning the knowledge is
there but somebody's not doing it right
and in surgery in other parts of
Medicine what we're finding is that the
amount of knowledge the volume the
complexity the tons of papers coming
across the transom the technologies that
are proliferating that all of it has
exceeded our abilities as individuals to
hold it all in our head and do it right
and there are lots of fields it turns
out where this has been happening
constructing buildings well in making
good investment decisions by hedge funds
and when I looked to see how people who
actually are solving these problems
we're solving it I thought you'd find
that they had just trained in a
different way or they had been they were
training longer and harder they had a
different kind of use of technology
instead what I found over and over again
was they use checklists
as simple and mundane as it sounds that
the checklist in a way filled in for
weaknesses in people's brains things
that they forgot it also filled in for
weaknesses and making teams work teams
constantly drop stuff between the cracks
and so we made a checklist based on what
I learned actually I've got folks from
Boeing to help us out how do you make a
checklist I didn't think that that would
be all that hard it turned out to be
hard and one of the things they showed
us was how to how to really focus on
making it Swift and usable we made a
two-minute surgery checklist had just 19
items some of them were just make sure
you don't forget dumb stuff make sure
you gave antibiotics make sure you have
blood ready for a high blood loss case
and then there were other interesting
parts make sure everything in the room
has been introduced by name and roll
make sure the surgeon actually explained
to the team what their goals for the
operation are make sure the
anesthesiologist a nurse had a chance to
explain their plans for the operation I
put we put that checklist in eight
hospitals around the world ranging from
rural tanzania to Toronto and Seattle
and every single Hospital put it in and
had a double digit reduction in
complications the average reduction in
death was forty six percent that made me
realize there was something much deeper
and more important going on here about
the set of problems we're grappling with
in the modern world
well on the one hand you'd say 0% when
you look at we have about 13,000
diagnosis we've recognized the human
body to have four we have 6,000 drugs
4,000 different kinds of medical and
surgical procedures and the and we know
for each of them there's anywhere from
half a dozen too many dozen steps that
we should make sure are done correctly
and we just rely on human memory the
person in the office that you go to to
just remember what that stuff is and we
drop stuff all the time a friend of mine
went in for a depression she she was
just becoming really low the doctor put
her on an antidepressant and for the
next three years they're changing
antidepressants trying to get it right
it was only much later three years that
they realize oh we didn't check your
thyroid hormone level and she just had
low thyroid hormone levels two weeks of
thyroid hormone and she was better she
lost three years because of that so the
surgery checklist is in place in about
twenty percent of American hospitals
some countries have implemented it
nationwide France the United Kingdom
places like Ecuador are adopting it
nationwide but but our people really
using it in their heart of hearts are
they in there well in the surgery world
we are adopting it but have we recognize
the lesson that maybe this is the way we
ought to think about that we ought to
have literally pick up a checklist when
you come in with a new problem that
we're not there with every time you get
on an airplane someone picks up a
checklist
well there are there's a cultural
obstacle we see checklists as a weakness
as individual practitioners you know if
you were in seeing a surgeon they said I
better check a textbook on this or I
want to check my checklist we were not
there yet culturally we're starting to
be the second obstacle is any old
checklist is not the story here I mean
we could end up just creating a bunch of
paperwork and tick boxes that that just
get ignored and aren't really valuable
so the institutional obstacle is we have
to recognize this as a science in the
aviation world we have a National
Transportation Safety Board that goes in
and investigates accidents and shows the
lessons that a Boeing or an Airbus then
can adopt into checklists and just
making the lessons usable we need the
same thing a kind of medical safety
board a National Institute for Health
Systems innovation is what I would call
it that would recognize for being
discharged to go home from a hospital
there are six key components to a
checklist that every hospital should
have that we know make a difference in
reducing the likelihood that you're
going to bounce back into the hospital
we print two-inch-thick guidelines
saying what you should do for cardiac
care but we haven't boiled it down to
here are the six things one should never
forget when you're in there with that
patient complaining of chest pain
you